hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 american science fiction and action
movie called the adam project
the movie begins with a middle-aged man
in 2050 adam reid stealing a time
traveler jet and is being chased down by
the authorities while suffering from a
gunshot wound
he is capable of getting away from the
missiles and navigating the jet until it
is ready to project a wormhole that will
take him to leap into another period
he succeeds leaving his chasers puzzled
meanwhile in 2022 adam is still 12 years
old and is being a bully target at
school due to his big mouth and short
stature
the bullies ray and chuck attack him
until he bleeds then they are both being
suspended at school
ellie his mother picks him up from
school and scolds him for being such a
troublemaker adam argues that his mother
does not understand him unlike his dad
who just passed away in an accident over
a year ago
in the evening ellie is preparing to go
on a date with her co-worker and leaves
adam alone at home
he spends his time playing video games
on a virtual reality device when a power
surge suddenly happens he accompanies
his dog hawking to look around the house
then checks the woods behind his house
he finds newly burned trees then hears
sounds at his dad's garage when he
rushes to check what is inside he finds
the 2050 atom gasping for breath while
lying on the floor
hawking immediately rushes to him and
finds himself comfortable
the young adam is surprised to find a
stranger able to unlock his dad's garage
but he leads him into his house anyway
in the house old adam finds something to
eat drink and searches for medicine to
treat his wounds
young adam observes him how he
comfortably wanders around the house
knows exactly how to close the fridge
door knows his mother is out on a date
and knows both him and hawking's name
although initially refusing to explain
further old adam finally tells him the
truth that they are the same person they
are wearing their dad's old watch and
have the same stitch marks on their
necks
he continues to explain that he is
supposed to land in 2018 not 2022 as
part of a rescue mission to save someone
but he does not tell who
however he takes young adam back to the
woods where his jet is parked explaining
that that jet is specifically encoded to
his dna but will not recognize him when
he is badly injured
he uses young adam's finger to unlock
the jet for him and perform a
self-healing mechanism as the jet also
suffers from missiles and gunshots
he decides to stay a few days until the
jet completely repairs itself and he is
healed too young adam asks about time
travel to which he replies that there is
a fixed time where everyone is supposed
to live their lives but time travelers
like him can jump between time periods
and cause divergences however he needs
to do that due to his super important
rescue mission
when young adam asks what the future
would look like old adam replies that it
is still tragic
he sleeps inside their dad's garage and
young adam heads back to his house
before sleeping old adam stares at a
holographic photo of a woman
in the morning ellie is frantically
searching for his insurance document
before going to work while young adam
makes his breakfast and enjoys his
suspension day he goes to check old adam
who is going to a drugstore to buy
medicine to treat his wounds
outside the drugstore young adam
encounters his bullies again but old
adam encourages the fight to happen
however when young adam flees old adam
deals with ray himself to scare him out
turns out young adam already arrives at
dad's garage and locks the door to
personally check old adam stuff
he is also mad at him for not defending
him against the bullies old adam argues
that they need to lose and suffer many
times before they become who he is now a
time pilot capable of fighting
young adam finds the photograph and asks
who she is which turns out to be laura
adam's wife
in the evening old adam is hanging out
at a bar while ellie enters he
immediately recognizes her mother and
listens to her complaining about her son
to the bartender he cannot resist
jumping into the conversation and gives
very personal touching advice to ellie
on how to deal with his son and her
grief
he then leaves and is nowhere to be
found when ellie decides to look for him
outside
meanwhile adam's chasers led by maya
sorian arrive in 2022 to continue their
chase
she orders a troop to find adam and
bring him back to 2050.
the next day the atoms are having lunch
young adam asks again about laura then
deduces that old adam wants to go to
2018 to save her old adam theorizes that
saurian killed her or left her in the
past
young adam recognizes saurian maya
sorian as their dad's business partner
in the future saurian has seized control
over the time travel technology which
their dad accidentally invented in a
project called the atom project and is
not the good person she was back when
their dad was still alive
2018 is also the year when the first
particle time travel attempt succeeded
so old adam guesses laura has something
to do with that moment
he slowly feels an incoming threat then
gets ready with young adam to get out of
the house when saurian's troops appear
and attempt to apprehend him
old adam battles them while young adam
only watches in awe and guards old
adam's bag
sorian announces from her jet speaker
that she did not kill laura but old adam
does not buy it
suddenly saurian's jet is mysteriously
attacked from the woods as well as the
remaining troops circling the atoms
a figure appears who turns out to be
laura
managing to contain his relief old adam
helps her defeat the last of the troops
then embraces her in a long-awaited
reunion
laura then takes the atoms to her truck
then drives as fast as possible to
escape from saurian's regrouping troops
and jets after a close call in the woods
they successfully escape and arrive at
laura's hideout by the lake
turns out laura escaped from saurian's
assassination attempt but was not able
to go back to 2050 so she spent her life
in the past
she has been living in the past for four
years until she is now reunited with old
adam
from her story young adam deduces that
saurian already changed the fixed
timeline by going to her 2018 self to
help seize full control of the time
travel technology even before it was
invented
so old adam needs to go to 2018 to stop
time travel from ever being invented in
the first place and avoid all chaos in
the future as sad as he seems because he
needs to leave laura again old adam
finally leaves while laura buys them
some time to battle sorian's troops led
by christos sorian's lieutenant adam
does not have a clear idea of what he
needs to do but he is determined to ask
for help from his dad still alive at
that time
meanwhile sorian finds laura and shoots
her after she finds out adam
successfully gets to his jet and escapes
then she goes after the atoms chasing
their jet in the narrow gorges
old adam skillfully turns off his jet at
the right time and maneuvers to hide in
a cave so sorry and cannot detect him
while she reminds him through the radio
communication that adam's jet is still
heavily damaged and can only withstand
one last time jump
however the atoms still proceed with the
plan and make the jump
in 2018 louis their dad is giving a
lecture when the atoms discover him old
adam makes young adam promise not to
tell their dad too much stuff of the
future including his fate encountering
them after the class ends louis
immediately recognizes old adam as his
son but refuses to help them as it will
jeopardize the fixed time in the evening
the adams are still trying to convince
louis at a motel but he is firm on his
decision heading home to his own family
old adam scolds him for not being a
better father and only cares about
physics rather than a son
after louis leaves young adam tells old
adam that even though he is his younger
self he realizes that he does not hate
his dad because he is more inclined to
his work rather than his family but
because he died
it is easier to be angry at someone
rather than miss them so adam copes with
grief by being angry at his dead father
however anger and sadness are two
different feelings
old adam is startled by his younger self
and starts to compose himself again
meanwhile 2050 saurian goes to meet her
2018 variant the young sorian is annoyed
to find her but old saurian convinces
them that they are in big threat if the
atoms succeed in erasing time travel
forever
the next day louis out of his routine
tries to cook and takes more care of his
family which surprises ellie
meanwhile the atoms get into sorian's
company headquarters to destroy louis
particle accelerator
young adam is tasked to control a remote
device able to sense and engage with
threats while old adam walks himself to
the building's front
the front of the building is early quiet
which makes old adam guesses that the
2050 saurian troops have been prepared
for their arrival
turns out his guess is true so they both
battle the troops a car almost hits old
adam when it is suddenly hit by another
mysterious car leaving old adam very
close to being hit
turns out it is louis who changed his
mind and intends to help the atoms in
their mission
meanwhile young adam who stations
himself at the building's roof is caught
by saurian inside the building louis
explains that they should not go after
the particle accelerator as sorian can
easily rebuild it the hard drive
containing his time-traveling enabling
algorithm they should take
when louis pulls out the hard drive the
saurians and the troops come in and
threaten them to return the hard drive
seeing his son at gunpoint louis begs
old adam to give up the drive but turns
out old adam is signaling at his younger
self to move so he would miss sorian's
aim
she shoots the particle accelerator
instead causing core instability and it
begins to form a magnetic field that
attracts objects around it the iron
armored troops are stuck to the field
and the atoms can battle the rest of the
troops the saurians take cover while
instructing christos to take the hard
drive from old adam however he is
defeated then the atoms reunite with
louis but they are interrupted by the
saurians once more old saurian convinces
her younger self to shoot louis but she
seems hesitant to do it old saurian
takes the gun herself and aims to shoot
him but due to the bullet's material it
deflects from its course as it is
attracted by the particle accelerator's
magnetic field and pierces through young
sorian instead
her death also wipes out old saurian's
existence
louis and the atoms escape in time
before the particle accelerator
initiates lockdown particle and safely
gets home
they play catch in the backyard
reminiscing the adam's good memories
about their father before they disappear
returning back to the fixed time
years later young adam has changed his
attitude and becomes more loving toward
her mother and when he grows old he
finally experiences his exact first
encounter with laura
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching